it was racist you see it was racist not
to immediately offer her a tenured
position but to consider it and then
offer her the ten-year position
okay hannah jones saying that there's a
fundamental attack on free speech while
she runs around the country
being handed awards money it's it's
hysterically funny
this is the beautiful thing about the
the crew that believes that america's
such a terrible place
that is replete with racism and bigotry
is nothing is ever enough like literally
nothing is ever enough
perfect story on this today and i i i do
say i have to love it
so university of north carolina you'll
recall offered the proverican a
professional liar and prevaricator
nicole hannah jones
who has suggested that america is
endemically and institutionally racist
on every level promoted riots during
has suggested that the destruction of
property does not amount to violence
has lied about america's police they
offered her tenure
remember they offered her a tenured
position at university of north carolina
based on her vast
academic qualifications which include
and also
okay so they offered her that then the
board of trustees like well maybe we
should think about that for a second
what if we just offered her a non-tenure
track position
and everyone knows how dare that no it's
cancellation cancel
okay and then they came back and they
voted nine to four to give her tenure
well now after having after having
forced
the entire university of north carolina
into submission nicole hannah jones has
now humiliated them
by saying she's not going to take the
tenured position instead she's going to
head on over to historically black
college howard university which is also
hiring
ta-nehisi coates according to the
huffington post
hannah jones will become a tenured
member of the faculty at the
historically black universities
kathy hughes school of communications
made the announcement tuesday during an
interview with gayle king on cbs this
morning
the unc alumna will take on the role as
inaugural night chair in race and
journalism
and will begin her faculty role this
summer
hannah jones will also lead the
university's newly created center for
journalism and democracy which will
train the next generation of black
journalists in investigative and
foundational journalism skills because
nothing says
investigative and foundational
journalism skills but like lying about
american history ignoring
historians who are actually qualified
and disparaging them as white
the center will seek to work with other
journalism programs at historically
black colleges and universities across
the country
hannah jones said quote we're at a
critical juncture in our democracy and
yet our press does not reflect the
nation it serves and too often struggles
to grasp the danger for our country
as we see growing attacks on free speech
and the fundamental right to vote said
okay hannah jones saying that there's a
fundamental attack on free speech while
she runs around the country
being handed awards money tenured
positions
it's it's hysterically funny tanahasi
codes will also join the faculty at hbcu
the roles are funded thanks to more than
20 million dollars in financial
contributions from the knight foundation
macarthur foundation the ford foundation
and an anonymous owner because again the
institutions of the united states
are geared toward radicalism they are
geared toward radicalism
and the institutions of the united
states have been mobilized on behalf of
the radical left it's why my book the
authoritarian moment is really important
go pre-order a copy right now
members of the faculty at the unc
hussman school of journalism and media
said in a statement they were quote
disappointed but not surprised at hannah
jones's decision to turn down the
school's offer
they said we support ms hannah jones
choice the appalling treatment of one of
our nation's most decorated journalists
by her own alma mater was humiliating
inappropriate and unjust we will be
frank it was racist you see it was
racist not to immediately offer her a
tenured position but to consider it and
then offer her the ten-year position
it was so racist that now she's slam
dunk and she's just dunking on them
love it well you know what love it hats
off respect
respect man spectacular okay but this
this goes to a broader issue okay the
broader issue in american life right now
is that it is great to be a member of
the intersectional coalition
if you're a member of the intersectional
coalition you have endless power in
american life
you are able to skew any narrative in
your own favor
you're able to take advantage of every
opportunity and to slam dunk on people
who even offer you opportunities
you get to pretend to be the height of
virtue while ruining all your enemies
being a member of the intersectional
coalition has all privilege and no
fallout
you can be gwen berry an obscure hammer
thrower for the olympics and as soon
as you make a face into a camera during
the national anthem you're gonna get a
contract with nike i'm sure
if you are nicole hannah jones you can
be absolute garbage at your job
and it doesn't matter they will hand you
the editorship of the new york times and
fire anybody who crosses you
and then you'll be offered a 10-year
university position at a major publicly
funded university and turn it down
i mean man it's for a country that is so
all fired racist and sexist
it is unbelievable to be a member of the
intersectional coalition taking
advantage of this
on an intellectual level it really is
how's this for a title
ben shapiro show subscriber destroys
like button with clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang